a navy hospital ship will leave Virginia
today to bring medical help to Puerto
Rico the USNS comfort will deliver
urgently needed personnel and supplies
including units of blood it will assist
areas where medical facilities are
crippled chip Reeves at the Naval
Station in Norfolk where the ship is
ready for its fourteen hundred and
twenty mile journey to Puerto Rico chip
good morning
well good morning as you can see that is
one big floating Hospital and it has an
even bigger mission to bring relief to
thousands of Puerto Ricans who are
desperate for medical care when that
ship leaves this port later today it
will have more than 850 service members
on board and 70 civil service Mariners
it will travel with five thousand units
of blood for x-ray machines a dental
suite a pharmacy even a physical therapy
center the comfort was on the Gulf Coast
after hurricanes Rita and Katrina in
2005 it was in Haiti after the
devastating earthquake in 2010 and it
was in New York City after 9/11 now the
comfort is always ready to deploy within
five days of getting the order in this
case though it didn't get the order
until Tuesday which was six days after
Maria hit Porto Rico some are asking why
it didn't happen sooner but we're told
one reason is that Maria created 35 foot
waves very dangerous waves just off the
coast Norah all right chip thank you so
much